which brings us to the topic of the day
so me and you we've been friends for
such a long time I think it's like over
eight years been a long time [ __ ] dude
it's hard but it was like when we all
kind of men like the friendship just
clicked it was like one of those natural
like you didn't have to pretend or like
flirt we just were friends and we just
stuck together like that but for the
longest time you know like me and Bart
we we kept the race hidden you knew who
we were like you know we did it because
for other reasons that we explained but
like recently when I did come out and
things like that and we we do videos
together I've been noticing like there's
things like oh I can't believe David
like hangs out with all these
non-koreans he's not Korean enough or
whatever Japanese evil people are they
yeah they use our people are like a
piece of [ __ ] but then you get flack for
not being Korean enough yeah well like I
get you know like there's controversy
obviously oh why did you hide yourself
that you were Japanese were you ashamed
of that exactly between Japanese and
Korean and things like that but like we
really don't look into those stupid-ass
things yeah and you know did that man
there's so many things to talk about
that like in general like let's just
start with this right I was always
taught specifically because I grew up in
a Christian household to judge people
for who they are as individuals so your
did your family kind of tell you the the
all the the struggles they went through
through the war and stuff no no did they
did they do it like your grandparents
must've right no my grandpa my dad my
grandpa was dope dude this fool fled
this [ __ ] and the war is
happening he got in a little boat with
his family went to an island Wow
so there was a lot of Korean people that
did that because I didn't want to be a
part of the war yeah and they didn't
want to die
I see so they they they escaped off I
guess like two small islands or
something like that that's from what I
remember and there was like a like a
group of people that just did that and
waited the war out yeah cuz they were
scared they didn't want to die and
that's that's what my grandpa did and I
think my aunt was born off the coast of
some kind of small island or some [ __ ]
like that my eldest your personal your
family personally didn't go through
me tragedies do through the hands of
Japanese people maybe my mom side did
but my mom doesn't talk much about her
family you know and we had relatives
that did but like I said my dad doesn't
dwell in the past
yeah and that's something that I learned
from my father a lot he doesn't dwell in
the past he understands the history he
understands what happened and what went
on yeah but he does even my grandpa
doesn't though I'll put it to you like
this man my grandpa could write in
Japanese and in Chinese or whatever in
hundun which is like Chinese and stuff
it was taught to him at that age and he
would show me like hey look you know I
could write in Japanese and all this
other stuff Wow he didn't say it like
you know [ __ ] Japanese people yeah
I hate those a [ __ ] job you know he
didn't do any of that yeah showed me
that he could do it damn and my grandpa
didn't tell me stories about hate either
yeah in my family like that I think we I
guess my family deals with it in like
that happened it was [ __ ] up but we're
gonna move on from it yeah and I think
that was the whole the Christian side of
things I mean but there are still
Christians that can't let go like it's
not just a Christian thing right it's
just I think your family knows how to
forgive yeah because I did have other
Korean Christian friends that they just
they they always had to bring it up and
then like I'm like I didn't do anything
you know that I'm gonna get into
religion but that's yeah price like yeah
but you're right like I mean I think
there's a lot of hypocrites no matter
where you go right like but my first
experience of that when I was a kid is
like my mom didn't tell me anything
about like that stuff right yeah and
they didn't deny it they just told me
like you know we Japanese people did a
really bad thing during World War two
that's what they told me as a kid yeah
and then one time my Korean friend in
elementary school was having a sleepover
but then like I wasn't allowed and then
and then and my friends like sorry you
can't come because you're Japanese
and I'm like why and he goes well my
grandma says she doesn't want you there
and then he was crying he was sad about
it because he didn't understand you
didn't understand I didn't understand I
was sad about it so I went home and I
told my parents about it and my parents
were like nah forgive him it's cool and
in debts when they told me the stories
about like how Japanese people bullied
everybody and not everyone's gonna like
you because of that reason so I was like
oh man that really sucks because we're
kids and it's like and you have to pay
for that right and in the my friends
grandma is perpetuating it yeah I mean
she probably went through something
really [ __ ] up yeah for her to like
project her hate toward a child uh-huh
but then I don't know like I also don't
can't say anything cuz I'm like yeah I
don't know what happened I don't know
what kind of pain she went through you
know and I think like the the sad part
about that is like I don't want to
transfer hate over yeah right so for
your friends grandma rightfully so she
should be angry that's something that
she went through a hundred percent man
and I can never but she should be mad at
the people that did wrong to her yeah
I'm not to the kid not to the random kid
that's born in America and even to that
point to like I but I still understand
where she's coming from it's so you know
there's I don't know if you people even
know about this but there was something
called like comfort women well yeah you
know like women in Korea were used as
sex slaves yeah like that's about some
areas [ __ ] up [ __ ] you know and when I
hear about those stories it makes me sad
yeah but when I look at a Japanese
person I don't see that though yeah I
see the history that happened and this
could be from a Korean American
perspective you know what I mean but I'm
also saying this too
I have relatives and friends in Korea
and they also vibe with this same
concept - yeah they travel to Japan
consistently from work and even just
from work for fun I have a friend in
Korea right now that has a Japanese wife
yeah you know what I mean so you know
for for people to come out and say like
you don't know what it's like to be
Korean no you actually just see it in
your small perspect exactly I see it
from I'm trying to see it from
everybody's perspective and yes it's
anecdotal cuz I'm saying it from my
friends in Korea that are like that
I forgot what they're called but they
were in Japan since like throughout
history there's always been Korean
immigration yeah but they changed their
name to Japanese names but they're a
hundred percent ethnically Korean Oh